bonsoir paulo avec nous en direct sur la
défense alors la justice italienne qui
va donc entendre giuseppe compter demain
sur la gestion de l'épidémie
concrètement sur quoi va porter cette
audition écoutez il ya un sur le fait
que le gouvernement est accusé à l'heure
actuelle de n'avoir pas décrété ces deux
zones comme zone à risque on se renvoie
la balle entre le gouvernement central
et la région comprend pas très bien de
qui est la responsabilité c'est à dire
que en fait l'italie contrairement à la
france est un pays on a vu pendant la
crise avec des pouvoirs très très fort
au niveau régional et ils ont le rôle
la décision sur les zones dépendez aussi
de la région lombardie donc il ya un
petit peu un renvoi de balle en train de
cesser un dossier assez assez compliqué
obscures le président du conseil a dit
qu'il n'a aucune raison de se de
s'inquiéter de ça il va vraiment témoins
juste fait son devoir
et après si on peut conclure on peut
dire que c'est plutôt rassurant parce
que aujourd'hui le fait qu'il y ait de
la place pour les polémiques ça veut
dire que la situation sanitaire s'est
amélioré fortement parce que quand on
est en pleine crise sanitaire on n'a pas
le temps de faire le ballet des
polémiques donc c'est plutôt rassurant
qui est d'aider polémique parce que
c'est un peu un retour à la normale
comme l'italie est un pays de polémique
politicienne non un peu comme la france
aussi ça au moins on se réjouit de sac
le temps de la crise sanitaire a en tout
cas c'est le plus virulente est derrière
nous et on va voir qu'est ce qu'ils vont
dire de ce ce dossier en tout cas c'est
c'est important et aussi pour les
parents des victimes et/ou de voile a
dit voir plus clair parce que
effectivement c il y a des côtés dans la
gestion qui sont grèce obscures en
italie comme en france comme partout il
ya aussi chose à dire on était tous face
à un virus à quelque chose de
complètement neuf pour tout le monde et
donc effectivement il
c'est sûr et certain qu'il ya eu des
lacunes qu'il peut y avoir eu des voix
là parce qu'on faisait face à un ennemi
qui était complètement nouveau pour tout
le monde donc on avançait dans le noir
est malheureusement là pas la science
infuse peut-être il ya eu des erreurs et
on va voir qu'est ce que va dire la
justice
alors justement vous parliez un des
proches des victimes paolo levi il ya
une cinquantaine de plants ne s'est pas
rien déposé par des proches de victimes
du virus est la première action de
groupe en italie à propos de la pandémie
on sent quand même beaucoup de de colère
dans le pays
on va attendre réellement des comptes
comme en france d'ailleurs où il ya eu
pas mal de plaintes aussi contre contre
les ministres oui oui c'est sûr et
certain et c'est un droit on est en
démocratie donc il faut avoir confiance
dans la magistrature je pense en italie
il ya un système judiciaire qui certes
est lent mais qui est très garantie
s'était développée donc on va voir
qu'est-ce que ça va être c'est sûr que
qu' il faut éclaircir certains certaines
décisions qui ont pu être prises et on
va voir dans le lot qui était
responsable de quoi à l'heure actuelle
il n'est pas très clair si le
gouvernement était vraiment responsable
des régions où on a un peu l'impression
que les régions et gouvernement central
sera en bois un peu la balle et et on va
voir qu'est ce que ça va donner en tout
cas c'est très très intéressant et on
peut se réjouir au moins du fait que si
on parle de ça c'est que la crise
sanitaire et qu'on a vu l'hécatombe
qu'on a vu il ya quelques semaines est
derrière nous et airs espérant qu'elle
se reproduise pas à cet automne quand
peu probable il y aura une deuxième
bague espérant que l'italie et l'europe
soit plus préparés pour y faire face
oui effectivement 34 mille morts dont le
rappel en italie une question sur la
justice justement parce que hier on
parlait en france de cette cour de
justice de la république très
controversé
dénoncé par certains comme une justice
d'exception qui va justement jugé ces
ministres qui font l'objet de plantes
dans la gestion du corridor en italie
c'est pas le cas c'est véritablement la
justice de droit commun qui va entendre
le premier ministre
oui oui en italie c'est la justice le
droit commun ces deux systèmes
constitutionnels de constitution
différentes donc il n'y a pas cette cour
de justice de la république
en italie comme en france mais le
premier ministre comptait il va
tranquillement il et il a dit qu'il est
serein on va voir qu'est ce qu'il va
dire pour l'instant rien n'a filtré sur
ce qu'ils 1 qu'il va dire sur sa ligne
de défense je pense qu'il va renvoyer
lui aussi la balle au niveau régional
parce que c'est ce qu'on on a fait
jusqu'ici pas lui directement mais un
petit peu de yassa dans l'air le
gouvernement central et la lombardie qui
se renvoient la balle dans dans cette
polémique et on irait un match de ping
pong alors dernière question peut-être
davantage sur le déconfinement vous
parler de cette épidémie qui est
derrière vous on le souhaite tous petite
question avant de terminer quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui en italie le
déconfinement va s'accélérer aucune
résurgence du tout de l'épidémie
qu'en est il du nombre des
contaminations à nouveau des gens qui à
3,3 par en avant et en arrière mais mais
ça s'améliore nettement ça c'est moi
j'ai eu ma famille au téléphone
aujourd'hui ils me disent que par
exemple à rome la vie et retourner
presque normale et il ya très peu de
gens malheureusement qui porte le masque
ce qui est à déplorer mais voilà il ya
une envie de retour à la normalité je
parle de rome qui est une ville un peu
moins touchée par rapport à la lombardie
qui en revanche est emiland ont croqué
qui a souffert beaucoup plus et où la
situation reste encore sous surveillance
mais mes doigts et espérons que d'ici
le début de l'été on puisse retourner à
une vie presque normale quoi que l'état
d'urgence sanitaire aux parcs faut pas
l'arrêter d'un moment à l'autre il faut
que qui se soit arrêtée de façon
progressive sur les prochains de trois
mois et après on verra ce que nous
réservera l'automne parce qu'on ne sait
pas s'il va y avoir vraiment une
nouvelle badens en tout cas il faut
absolument que l'italie et l'europe face
à nous et le monde entier soit soit plus
préparé je pense qu'on va pas se faire
prendre de court comment ça a été le cas
au mois de mars
merci par l'olivier correspondant
italien basé à paris on va à l'essai
vous mettra à l'abri avec l'orage qui
gronde actuellement dans la capitale
merci à vous